[Musique]
il a perdu
je suis hélas
mais le jeu c'est est ici
il a changé tout parce qu'il est énervé
[Musique]
mon goût
tu veux la perruque
je m'élance non non non non non non non
non non papa tu acceptais jeu je ne
compte plus le mental joue et je veux
pas public d'accepter de langues dans le
monde
bon bah tu vois tu ne touches pas
tu me touches pas des mauvais jours je
ne touche pas
dany dis moi qui est chose que je ne
sais pas et moi je dirais quelque chose
que tu ne sais pas je dis je d'un
vendeur de fois ai-je et du crayon noir
pour que tous soient d'accord
si mme ljuba banon qui est noir non j'ai
revu mon axe qu'en un mois la première
année qu'on était ensemble
sur la wii si je te dis tu savais pas
mais au moins c'est bon c'est faute
avouée faute pardonner
[Musique]
la pince moi musée
la nouvelle
radio
abc
[Musique]
oui